there's some pretty stark research out
there now that oddly enough I think
doesn't get quite as much attention as
it deserves them just talk about one
study this was done by a German
scientist look at 2500 committed couples
so no small number the results are
probably no fluke and he measured their
desire progressively over time within
their committed relationships the desire
starts at right about the same point for
the men and for the women so again
debunking this idea that somehow male
desire male libido is far stronger
innately than female libido but what
happens interestingly is that male
desire declines gradually over time
female desire dives much more
dramatically than male desire within
those committed relationships and I
think two things are worth saying first
again the very least this calls into
question this idea that somehow women
are comparatively better suited to
monogamy than men are but second I think
the reason for the disparity showing
women even less well suited sexually for
monogamy than men has to do with
cultural lessons and their effects on
the brain so I think most of us have
heard this phrase or at least are
familiar with the concept of brain
plasticity that is the brain is shifting
neurologically sometimes slightly
sometimes a significant amount in
response to what we do with it it's why
we're told to do lots of crossword
puzzles as we get older will strengthen
our memories a bit that's a sort of
simplistic form of the brain plasticity
concept well what happens to the brain
if we're taught very different lessons
about sexuality from early on boys are
of course taught right from the
playground really that being a little
bit of a Romeo all to the good girls are
a very different and more constrained
lesson even in our seemingly
unconstrained society and that lesson
for those two divergent lessons
continued right on up through high
school you know I've had first-hand
experience with this with a you know son
and daughter who are now just finishing
or just graduate from college and this I
believe and I think researchers are are
starting to look into this has its
effect on the brain it's has its effect
on the robustness of those neurological
paths that have to do with arrows and I
think what we're seeing within the
monogamous relationships is that the
male neurological sexual pathways being
built up over time and being somewhat
more robust are in a way more resilient
to that natural decline
whereas women's may not be may need more
of a charge may need more novelty and so
again if we're just focusing on
sexuality itself on eros itself for that
reason women may be feeling even more of
a decline than men within those
long-term committed relationships